okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today
i'm going to be talking about some [ __ ]
that happened to me this week
so as you guys know i had a clip that i
put on my instagram or maybe you don't
know okay my instagram's just dot pearly
things
and in that clip i'm gonna read what it
was i pissed some people off apparently
i am so tone deaf
i hate women
like i i don't know because i don't have
kids okay this is what i said
i said
i do not feel i do not feel bad for
women that get rejected because of their
weight i have been overweight
statistically and it was my own damn
fault i had like 205 i'm six foot you
should not be 205 if you're six foot you
shouldn't okay but i did you know [ __ ]
happens
i have been overweight statistically and
it was my own damn fault it was
and you can lose it you can
if your wife gets pregnant and does not
lose the weight and he leaves i agree i
agree with the men i understand if a
girl gains 10 20 pounds whatever like
whatever you know your body changes a
little bit
but if you're getting 50 75 pounds
after a child
and some girls do it without the kid
they gain this weight and they're not
even pregnant they get the ring and
they're like let's let myself go i have
a husband he'll stay no matter what so
why do it to please him yeah he has a
right to leave you he does does the
woman have the same right i was asked he
and i said yes the woman i would say the
same thing if a guy gains a ton away now
why why were people offended by this
because people don't like the truth they
don't like being honest and they don't
like giving men
right this is what's crazy okay
all the time we'll say like a woman can
leave because she's not happy
a woman can leave because she just
doesn't feel herself anymore like epray
loves type [ __ ] like she left her
husband to go to india
and do what
a woman can leave
because he's not financially stable he's
like a bum okay
and i and i give women have the right to
leave for whatever they want and i say
the same thing for men i think being not
sexually attracted to your partner is a
big
problem that that's an issue okay you
want to be with someone that is sexually
attracted to you and even if you're the
wife that got left because she gained
weight do you want someone to have pity
sex with you
i wouldn't what the
like
so
i'm not talking about slight changes to
your body because you had kids i'm
talking about women that let themselves
get obese
obese
and i'm not talking about men that leave
the second they're women's lead gains
really stop a little bit of weight i'm
talking about men
that
tell their wives or feel like they can't
tell their wives okay
that they're gaining weight and they're
not sexually attracted to them anymore
that's an important part of a marriage
so yeah men men have the same right that
women do
they can leave for whatever reason they
want i don't think you should stay with
someone you're not sexually attracted to
i think you should communicate to them
first your problems
and you know i think in some instances
you stay for the kids because it's
better for the kids to be together you
know
but
what i'm saying is men are allowed to
have standards and
you women get so up in arms
um so then i looked at like i was
looking at the comments on this video
because i had oh my gosh my best friend
20 years so she can't be friends with me
anymore because of it crazy thing is i'm
like i wasn't even talking about you but
if the shoe fits that's not my fault
that is not my fault
never said never said your husband
should
i said he can and they have that right
and it's not my fault if the shoe fits
okay
this is this is the the comments that i
got i have no kids i could never
understand again my mom had seven kids
okay she gained a little bit of weight
after the kids but she did not let
herself get morbidly obese
and she actually i take it back she was
obese for a little bit
and you know what she did she lost the
weight
and my whole life my mom always told me
she always told me
to stay in shape and i hated her for it
for a long time because she was always
telling me like what to eat and always
like if i gained weight she might say i
would always knew my mom would say
something put on some makeup like
because naturally guys i'm just a tomboy
i don't like makeup i don't like i like
looking homeless that's my thing
and my whole life i hated i hated that
my mom was always on my ass about that
[ __ ] and now i'm grateful because all my
friends are fatter than me like all my
friends whose moms were supportive no
matter what they're all fatter than me
i'm not even in amazing shape i'd like
to be 20 pounds lighter still
but
over time i'm glad my mom made me
obsessed and
insecure about it okay
second they're saying well my husband
you've never been in a mature
relationship guys keep your beta
husbands with no backbones i don't want
them
i want a guy that would stand up for
himself
do i want a guy that would be okay with
me getting morbidly obese
no keep your damn husbands
bro okay
um let me look at what else
okay then another person commented i
don't want my future daughter seeing
this ma'am what's what's meaner to your
daughter
getting morbidly obese like that is the
meanest thing you can do to a kid is
raise them in a household with habits
that make them obese and i know this
because before my mom lost all the
weight i was that kid
that had those horrible eating habits
and half the reason i'm motivated to
stay in shape and like get better with
this stuff
is because i want to raise a family and
i don't want my kids to struggle with
weight the way i did my whole life i was
a chubby kid
and and so they'll they'll pat
themselves on the back and say what
feels nice but that's not nice
it's not kind
to let your kid
grow up in an environment where you tell
them it's okay to be overweight because
it's not you are at such a disadvantage
in life if you are overweight
and i say that with love i don't say it
you lose your value as a person
but
this is the thing women get so emotional
because they let themselves go
and when they let themselves go
that's why they take it internally the
next thing
people will say is
um okay there's a difference with being
with someone for looks
and being with someone for who they are
as a person i agree there's more to it
than looks but guys it starts with looks
and if you let yourself get to a point
where your partner is no longer sexually
attracted to you
deal with the consequences
and even even if he stays there's still
going to be consequences in your
marriage you're going to find that he's
looking up other girls because you don't
look good anymore
and this isn't fun guys again none of
the [ __ ] i say is fun it's just it's
just true
or you'll find him going stepping out
and then this is the other thing women
do when they're wrong they give you
exceptions to the rule
we all know most women that get morbidly
obese made some poor choices to get
there that that is the rule
i did not say gaining a little bit of
baby weight i did not say getting chubby
i said getting morbidly obese putting on
50 75 100 pounds you made poor decisions
to get to that point just like when i
hit 200 pounds i made poor decisions to
get to that point
but women don't like accountability so
what they'll do is they'll take the
exceptions
pcos
women gain weight after after kids guys
people in the fifth if you look at
pictures from the 40s 50s 60s women
bounce back after that [ __ ] like they
still looked hot
like why why do we have this narrative
that after we have a kid we have to look
like [ __ ] i swear to god i'm a
it's gonna be a tough road i'm gonna do
my best to look like a damn
snack
no matter what so it's just crazy
because
women don't like the truth
and
i will never in my life
stop stop being honest with people
so that's me responding
to comments and clarifying what i meant
and what i said
but if you don't agree i don't care
don't follow me
anyways but for real subscribe if you do
agree because i'll be honest with you at
least
anyways bye